joining me now newt gingrich former
speaker of the house fox news
contributor
and ohio congressman jim jordan newt um
it's almost as if some gop members oh
they almost
seem like they don't want to win back
congress next year
given what they're supporting with the
so-called infrastructure
to track that's going to go to 4
trillion dollars soon
well look i think some of the
republicans
tend to take a short-term win and forget
the larger game
so they feel good they've been
bipartisan they're getting something
done
the fact that the thing they're getting
done first of all as you pointed out
they have no idea what's in the bill and
they have no veto
over what's in the bill and so they're
going to get a bill
which is dramatically worse than
anything they agreed to
they're going to have no ability to
change it and it's going to be a
disaster
and there's a wing of the republican
party which historically it's the wing
that reagan opposed
frankly it's the wing we opposed when i
was speaker of the house
and it's a wing which says that you've
always got to find a way
to be responsible and being responsible
means
selling out to the left and that these
17
many of them are good friends of mine i
have great respect for them but they are
they got suckered on this
it's the wrong thing to do they ought to
rethink it there'll be more than enough
reason to vote against this bill
when they actually see the bill remember
they haven't seen the written language
they don't know what they're for and
therefore
there are plenty of opportunities here
for them to decide you know
that was a mistake i don't think i can
go along with it
that's what they should do yeah well
that's 2700 pages long the
the so-called infrastructure bill
senator cassidy said he read it that's
got to be a evelyn woods speed reader
with the staff i guess
but congressman jordan um some
republicans including
uh robert rob portman fellow ohio
what what's going on here really because
it's obvious that this is a this is a
twofer
it's not a infrastructure on its own
yeah there's what's what's going on here
right there's only
only 10 of the bills devoted actual
infrastructure and i'll tell you what is
in the bill
is the word equity is mentioned over 60
times my guess is
in all the time the speaker gingrich was
in congress he never saw a
transportation bill or an infrastructure
bill that was focused on equity
so that's the problem with this it's a
bunch of left-wing spending it's part of
what i call the democrats crazy economic
plan which is
down economies spend like crazy pay
people not to work and oh by the way for
all of you who are working
they're getting ready to raise your
taxes such a deal so we know this is bad
what these republicans were thinking i
don't know because it's it's step one of
a bigger spending bill that's coming
later
and you rightly pointed this out last
night in your interview
with senator cassidy so uh this is bad
news it's part of the crazy democrat
spending and crazy economic plan
and frankly i think it's why we are
going to win i think if the election
were today we'd win big it's not today
it's next year but i think we're going
to win next year and take back the house
but new you do give away some of your
principled authority if the
wise men i put that in quotes in your
party
and there's some women in this too but
are are the people who give
biden this win on infrastructure
and glide right into 3.5 trillion
of family medical leave universal pre-k
to indoctrinate our kids all the rest of
the stuff in there
and bankrupting a future generation this
is insane what they're doing
i'm embarrassed to be called a
republican when they're supporting us
look this is the kind of behavior which
led to the rise of the tea party
from people who were in furious at the
failure of washington leadership
it's the kind of thing frankly which led
to 63 percent disapproval
of republican leaders in the congress
just before donald trump ran for
president
uh and in many ways people look at this
stuff and they think
you know what what's the point why do we
raise the money why do we go out to vote
yeah
if all we're going to do is get people
who get suckered in
i don't mind if they can't play chess
but if they can't play tic-tac-toe
there's something really profoundly
wrong with
and when they get together for their
luncheon they ought to really look at
this
this is something they should bail on it
was a mistake
it will be dramatically worse than they
think and the 2700 pages
will be followed by 50 000 pages of
regulations
and there's more than enough reason for
those 17
senators to decide that they got
suckered and that the time has come to
kill it
not to move it forward yeah stop digging
in the hole and congressman jordan i
think it's important to see
how a former obama strategist
is describing the 17 in the romney group
watch
there's been no gop civil war it's been
a one-sided massacre
of anti-trumpest in the gop we are
beginning to see
green shoots emerge beneath the ice
of trump tribalism you're seeing it in
this bipartisan infrastructure deal
congressman the anti-trumpers outing
themselves in the gop
no i mean we just had a big win here in
ohio in a special election the candidate
president trump
endorsed one big trump president trump's
a leader of our party americans
appreciate that he did what he said he
would do
when he was president and that's why
we're going to win because these guys
have done so many crazy things whether
it's crime whether it's inflation
whether it's the crisis on the border
all those reasons are why i think we're
going to win
people are frustrated with these guys
and they're going to put republicans
back in charge
i can tell you newt gingrich did not
take the house back
after 50 years of gop being locked out
of the house
because of these types of votes that's
not why newt gingrich was able to take
that house back oh and i remember that
night very well
great to see both of you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else